do you have this thing where you know
when a crt tv is on in a house
it can be anywhere in the house but
there's a distinctive sound that rings
out and kind of penetrates walls
so that i specifically and maybe some of
you out there can tell
when a crt tv is on cathode ray 2 tv an
old tv a big boxy tv it's not that
common these days but
even if i'm walking outside i can tell
when someone has a crt tv
in their house and it's on it's that
distinctive
it's not that common these days so when
it does happen it's just like this
piercing noise
in my brain i think it's hearing unless
it's like sixth sense
but i also realized that as you grow
older your hearing steadily gets worse
now i can still hear those crt tvs and i
don't even know if it's that high of a
frequency that it's supposed to be
something distinctive
but i haven't had a hearing test since i
was in elementary school so i don't know
if my hearing's gotten worse as i've
grown
older so let's find out like your gender
male age 30 40 device headphones
cool i just one two three
one two three
one two three i hate this
one two three this is like the absolute
perfect start to some kind of horror
movie
just this voice counting one two three
your head two
three bouncing between ear and ear
two three just calling out to you you
don't know if you're crazy
two three maybe you're the only one that
can hear it maybe everyone else can
maybe they're all ignoring it three
maybe they know it's best to ignore it
one two three either way it's it's uh
it's fine
uh so if you're watching this put on
headphones we'll all take this together
and let me know in the comments what
your
hearing level is so if you have good
hearing then subscribe and ring the bell
because you'll be the only ones that can
actually hear the bell if you got bad
hearing
leave a like give me a thumbs up so a
visual indicator because hearing isn't
really in the question how this test
works this hearing test will help you
identify difficulties with understanding
speech in no
what wait this isn't a high pitch for
what you will hear different
combinations of words first and then
numbers always in groups of three
while background noise varies what kind
of scp foundation
test is this some kind of cognitive
[ __ ] they're gonna program my brain
select the three things you hear by
selecting the corresponding icon or
number shown to the left
okay this is much different than i
thought it was i'll get a different test
that actually is like the frequency test
but this is fascinating finally if
you're using hearing aids
we recommend that you remove them while
taking the test sure
hand tree cars
hand trees cars choose the words
cat bells king
cat bells kings
bells cars
[Music]
okay it's getting really difficult cat
tree bells
okay that was almost imperceptible cars
hand
tree choose the numbers seven
four six oh my god i nailed it
did any of you get that seven
four six choose the numbers eight
five seven okay
i'll give you a beat this time so you
can know eight five
seven choose the numbers four three
five four three
five choose the numbers five four
six you get that one
five four six choose the number four
jesus oh god and now there's a freaking
leaf blower outside
choose the words oh here we go write it
bells
chair cat okay bells chair cat
choose the words cat
bells king uh
cat bells king choose the words
king cat ham
okay king cat you know at the end of
this it's gonna like
unlock some deep level programming and
me
like some shadow state [ __ ] and i'm
gonna be like turned into an assassin
and i'm gonna go kill someone that i
don't know
it's giving me a target oh what was the
last one hand i think it was hand
choose the words
hand get the [ __ ] leaf blower
why now when i'm taking a hearing test
there's gonna be a leaf blower
why now why now why now leaf blower why
now
the one time i need to hear things
there's a leaf blower it's just making
it hard
[Music]
book bells chair choose the numbers two
eight three oh my god
choose the numbers eight five
seven i am going to go out i have to
murder someone
i have to this is the end of my this end
for me
i gotta go kill someone i have to i
literally have to go kill someone choose
the numbers
eight five seven
okay oh my god
it's [ __ ] oh
oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god choose the numbers
eight six three
eight six three are you you done you
done mr leaf blower you done
okay good
okay six five seven get my results
that's some [ __ ]
wait wait oh my god it just had me fill
out information
and then it said your result right here
it didn't even email me
my result resound gn you
are dead to me you are del monte dead to
me let's try something else
oh here we go here we go we got tones
this is what we're looking for this is
the tones
right here 500hz
it's like so quiet until you can only
just
hear the tone okay this is the test
okay i kind of hear that well this isn't
what i was hoping for well this is
baloney why is it so hard
why is it so hard just to find a test
okay humans hear frequencies from 20
hertz to
20 000 hertz as we get older exposed to
loud sounds which damage our ears
the upper limit decreases this test
helps you benchmark the highest boundary
of the system's frequency extension if
you can't hear any of the high
frequencies played back during the test
don't blame your speakers too quickly
unlike low frequencies high frequencies
are easily reproduced through smaller
and cheaper speakers
assuming your sound card is not prone to
aliasing please refer to the third
section below
the weakest components in this test are
your ears
well i don't know about you [ __ ] but my
ears are pretty
[ __ ] good so oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you for this one keep your
computer's audio levels down you don't
want to damage your hearing
use the voiceover as a reference keep it
quiet and you will be safe okay let's do
this
22 kilohertz 21k
20k 19k
18k oh 17.
oh 16. oh
15k whoa 14k
13k 12k
11k 10k
okay man i i wasn't paying attention to
where that came in i didn't realize it
was going to be starting at the top i
thought it was going to be starting at
the bottom and going way back up
so let's try that again 22 kilohertz
21k 20k
19k definitely there we go there we it's
right in between like 19k
16k okay so
it's right between like 18 and 19k so if
the upper limit is 20k
then i'm just short of the upper limit
that's at least the first thing that
i've seen
i want to do something that goes up okay
hearing test
one hurts oh at what frequency did you
start hearing sound let's do this
okay i'm ready
[ __ ] leaf blower are you serious
oh whoa i hear that oh yeah
so around 50 hertz everyone write down
what hurts you get
you get to
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay we're going in this everyone buckle
up thx is starting up
[Music]
probably uh this is what's going to
destroy my hearing and then i won't
actually be able to hear any more high
frequencies
because i don't typically listen to like
music or stuff
ah
okay well why'd it go so fast towards
the end there
here we go here we go freaking leaf
blower go away
go away go away mr leaf blower when do
we want to do on your schedule here
[Music]
okay three four five
six seven eight
nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen seventeen eighteen
can't hear nineteen fresh is a newborn
freaking newborns getting blasted by
audio
can you hear that uh so i cannot hear 19
in this one i can just barely hear 18
can't hear 19. and i can confirm this i
know
i actually know how to confirm this i
actually can't in premiere there's a way
that you can generate bars and tone now
it's not pleasant to listen to but if i
turn down the volume it shouldn't be too
terrible if the freaking leaf blower
would stop
if the freaking leaf blower would go
away this bar's in tone
the thousand okay let's go five thousand
see that's a nice tone that that that
pierces let's go 10k
oh 15 000.
that's like the most that's the range of
the most painful
ouch okay 16 000.
that's about crt level by the way oh my
god leaf blower man
leaf blower ma'am or lady ma'am leaf
blower ma'am or leaf blower man
okay seventeen thousand can hear that
eighteen thousand oh that's barely on
the edge there okay so let me try
seventeen thousand
five hundred yep seventeen thousand
fifty yep
yep definitely up there 17 900
yep 17 950
yep let's try 18 500. i don't think i'll
be able to hear this
i can tell it's there but i don't it's
not like i don't think i can actually
hear it so this is uh 18 4.
freaking leaflet man
i just want to do a nice hearing based
video
a sound based video an entirely sound
based video
do you guys know how much i hate leaf
blowers leaf blowers are the most absurd
invention
known to man they are just horrifying
for the environment it's the localized
way
of blasting exhaust fumes
in and around your home like what's the
point
okay whatever leaf blower suck but it
sounds like he's going away so let's
finish this goddamn test
okay 18 000.
i could dear i could hear that
definitely okay we're going 18-1
i can hear that 18-2
yeah i can hear that 18-4
i can barely hear that but i do know
it's there
yes okay i imagine 18.5 is going to be
where my hearing cuts off
i can barely hear that that's there but
that is super faint
it's it doesn't even sound like sound
186.
i can technically know that's on
yeah it's it's super weird it doesn't
even sound like sound at this point to
me
it's just like it's like someone's
taking a feather duster to my inner ear
and just going
okay 18-7 this might be completely gone
for me
i can tell okay i can tell there i'm
gonna assume though
that that's probably right about where
it would logically be gone i could tell
but barely
let's just go to nineteen thousand
ah i gotta twitch what the [ __ ] did you
see that i just got a cramp in like my
forehead that was super weird yeah it's
that thing where it doesn't sound like
sound
but i know when it's playing versus when
it's not
yeah sorry if this is like absurdly
damaging for
some people let's go 20 000 here see
what this is like
i it's like yeah it's that thing i can
feel it but i think that's just because
i feel the pressure wave from the
headphones
i'm not hearing anything i'm just
feeling it but then again i guess
what is hearing except feeling but i
don't i wouldn't say that i'm hearing
that i think that i will call my hearing
about 18 700 is probably where i got cut
off
so just to compare this is 19.5
yeah it's like i can tell but not here
it's just turning my brain into mush
isn't it so there we go
this video went a little bit awry but
that's okay
in conclusion i think i have decent
hearing for my age because
i generally have not done much to damage
my ears i don't really listen to music
on high volume i don't really listen to
music in general in my casual
like spare time i don't go to concerts
really so i don't really
experience like just walls of sound too
much so overall in my life i have not
exposed myself to that many damaging
sounds that being said
this is something that no matter what
age you are your hearing will slowly get
worse over
time as you can tell i'm not up to 20k
hertz probably a lot of you
if you're younger you were hearing these
upper frequencies and it was probably
pretty painful
kind of sucked so keep that in mind
everyone grows old someday but if you
don't damage yours too much hopefully
you'll be able to hear
for a good long time thank you everybody
so much for watching
let me know you thought down in the
comments what you could hear what you
couldn't hear
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye